this is a dangerous game oh I know how
to do with fight hey what's up I'm Chris
Pratt and I'm Chris Walken and we're
gonna be playing first impressions did
you go first
yeah Milania barf all over amazing I'm
the dumbest character in the lego movie
one more time I'm the dumbest character
in the lego movie and I have batarangs
this is a dangerous game yeah it's a
very dangerous game obviously that was
supposed to be me why are there always
songs about rainbow Kermit
yes wow this is good um well I'm not
sure if you like if you know this person
all right
if you've ever seen this show but it's
here and it takes place is town cold sx
and i don't know if you've ever actually
heard of this person but yes nailed it I
got the Queen yeah no no it's this girl
it's from Gemma Collins from a show
called TOWIE The Only Way Is Essex you
know what the thing you say Chris I had
an awesome time working with you bud oh
that's a really good Owen Wilson Wow
really took the starch out of me when I
thought it wasn't very good
our dope country fire festival attendee
west fire festival that's the one of the
bid they fooled the people to go to that
festival they call me they burn them you
said it was a you said they said it was
gonna be a g5 and it was a g4 that flew
me there
that's the fire festival yes this is
gonna be so bad
no way your are the best the only way to
make a flambe is this have it on fire no
you're doing it wrong Gordon Ramsay yes
yes posh spice baby yes let's see yeah
you know I mind it was Whitney's going
did off it's a bit of a tallboy Lisa I'm
30 i foot of ground yeah boys boys it's
a bit of a surfer oh no no close close
oh yeah Thor Thor yeah that's great
thanks buddy that was really good again
yeah you're strong at this come on girl
okay here we go
I don't do this without doing something
that I'm gonna get
trouble I know that first time that I
thought but the Douglas yeh knocked me
out but you know then I took it out on
the event Holyfield's ear and and so I
came out and um and all I know how to do
with fight you know what I'm saying so
I'm still fight and you just woke a uh
how am i him do this one cookie but
don't be a fool
save yourselves come on baby rifle let
me or please we are not people playing
oh um Yoda yeah you know of course
really good Darth Vader in the end we're
both winners yeah when I got first place
and you got second Owen Wilson here and
I'm here with Gemma conan's and now we
had a really good time doing their first
impression anyways to get the guys on my
head boy oh it's not a really good show
I haven't seen the show but I heard it's
really good thank God
yo Owen Wilson let's go I just want to
do this all day yeah that was fun right
that's the best one so far you guys so
far thank you